sonst noch Fragen heißt dein Buch ja und
wir haben auch immer ganz viel fragen
unsere Eingangsfrage ist eigentlich fast
immer wie ist die Lage die Lage ist
vielschichtig sie ist wunderbar was die
persönliche Lage
betrifft den Kindern geht's gut meine
Frau auch und damit sind die wichtigen
Dinge im Leben für mich schon mal sehr
gut dran aber sie ist vielschichtig
denn wenn man sich die heutige Zeit
anguckt mit mit doch einer ganzen Reihe
von Verwerfungen dann sage ich wir haben
Krisenzeit und Krisenzeit ist auch immer
chancenzeit ist auch immer die
Möglichkeit einer Veränderung ich hoffe
dass wir sie ergreifen Krise heißt ja
auch eigentlich nur Veränderung es heißt
ja nicht dass es negativ ist per se nein
es heißt auch dass es negativ ist in dem
Sinne
weil wenn Zeiten der Verunsicherung in
einer Gesellschaft da sind dann passiert
es oft dass eine Gesellschaft auch
ausrutscht dass sie entgleitet dass es
einen Nährboden gibt für Despoten
Diktatoren Populisten
und das kann dann zum Teil sehr
gefährlich werden also insofern vorsicht
ist geboten du siehst aber auch deine
Arbeit in diesem Zusammenhang auch wenn
du ich sag mal hier geht's um sehr
alltägliche Dinge wie Sonnencremes
funktionieren was es mit den Tropfen auf
den Herdplatten auf sich hat die einfach
nicht verdampfen wollen ja
ähm aber ich sag mal das ist für dich
ein Bildungsauftrag wenn ich das richtig
verstanden habe es geht darum dass wir
ähm Jahre in der Schule sind und wir
lernen lateinische Vokabel wir lernen
Differentialrechnung wir lernen ich weiß
nicht Fotosynthese aber die simple Frage
wie groß muss ein Spiegel sein damit ich
mich ganz drin sehen kann können wir
interessanterweise nach 10 20 Jahren
Schulzeit nicht beantworten und ich
glaube da ist das Buch einfach der
Versuch diese ich sag mal eher
unwichtigen oder ja scheinbar
überflüssigen Fragen mal aufzugreifen
die aber doch einen Reiz haben wenn man
genau hinschaut das heißt wenn ich
verstehen möchte wie eine Sonnencreme
funktioniert ist das vielleicht am
Anfang leppisch aber ich verstehe
wirklich was passiert beim Sonnenbrand
und ich verstehe auch wirklich wie ich
mich dagegen schützen kann bis du denn
dann damit wie Physik oder wie
Wissenschaft oder Wissen ansonsten
gelehrt wird un zuufrieden Schule
ähm ja ich bin unzufrieden in mehrfacher
Hinsicht das erste ist dass wir als
Nation als Gesellschaft die Schule
völlig vernachlässigen im Kern gibt es
zwar einige politische Diskussionen aber
so richtig engagieren tut man sich nicht
ja also wenn die Ministerposten zu
verteilen sind äh dann ist es ist nicht
so dass der Bildungsminister sozusagen
erste Wahl ist und dass jeder sagt Bo
ich muss Bildungsminister werden wir
hatten vor einigen Jahren mal den Fall
da gab es in Deutschland einen
Forschungsminister und prompt gab's den
Posten Verkehrsminister und wup hat er
gewechselt fand ich schade ist nämlich
auch ein Signal zu sagen also
Verkehrsminister ist irgendwie wichtiger
als Forschungsminister sehe ich anders
warum weil
Bildung letztlich das ist was diese
Gesellschaft ausmacht so wohl im Kleinen
im individuellen bildung ist das was uns
verändert das was unsere Sicht auf die
Welt verändert was vielleicht auch dazu
führt dass es demnächst vielleicht nicht
so viele Krisen gibt Bildung ist aber
auch Voraussetzung für das was hier
stattfindet also
der Fortschritt in diesem Land gründet
speziell in Deutschland sehr auf
Naturwissenschaft auf Technik
wenn ich die nicht ernst nehme wenn ich
nicht merke dass sie auch was schönes
hat
gibt es immer weniger junge Menschen die
sie sich auch dafür entscheiden und in
der Folge fehlen uns Ingenieure wir
merken es heute schon du bist jetzt
Wissenschaftsjournalist nicht mehr
Wissenschaftler gibt's Momente wo du
sagst ach ich wäre jetzt gern dabei als
Wissenschaftler selber was rausfinden
selber was ja ich hab mach beides ich ja
also ich bin zum einen
im im
Aufsichtsrat bzw Kuratorium von einigen
maxpl Gesellschaften also insofern maxpl
Instituten insofern gibt es den direkten
Kontakt zu Wissenschaft und äh ich gucke
regelmäßig in die Sterne ich habe eine
Sternwarte also ich messe auch selber
das ähm ja den Reiz muss ich einfach
haben da kann man auch was selber ich
sag mal das ist ja nicht so dass
Amateure nichts entdecken die können ja
auch wirklich du bist kein Amateur aber
man kann selber mit man braucht nicht
dieses große gerät man kann s cken ne
ist also man kann natürlich entdecken im
kleinen wobei mein pledoyer auch ist es
geht nicht um das Entdecken im Sinne von
der erste Mensch der das gemacht hat das
äh ist sicherlich in der Regel das was
dann Fachleute machen aber wir entdecken
alle die Welt jeder von uns es gibt
einfach das erste Mal dass man das oder
das versteht das oder das erkennt
dieses Phänomen einem auffällt und ich
glaube diese Art von persönlicher
Entdeckung ist das was ich total
reizvoll finde war das der Grund diesen
Beruf zu ergreifen Neugier äh der Grund
meinen Beruf zu ergreifen
waren drei Dinge für mich persönlich ich
habe darüber sehr nachgedacht also ich
geh nicht zu denen die in den
Journalismus so reingerutscht sind es
war zum einen so dass die ich immer
etwas machen wollte was eine gewisse
gesellschaftliche Relevanz hat also
einen Job machen bei dem man nur Geld
verdient und sagt vielen Dank das war
nicht meins ich brauchte einfach so oder
brauche dieses Element
auch ja die die die Hoffnung zu haben
Gesellschaft mitzu verändern sich aktiv
dran zu beteiligen Argument 1 Argument
2 ich habe einen Beruf der fantastisch
ist weil ich ständig lernen darf und das
ist etwas was mir persönlich unendlich
viel Spaß macht einfach Dinge zu
verstehen das bereitet mir innerlich
Freude und das dritte ist
dass es ein Beruf ist der immer zwischen
zwei Welten ist das ist vielleicht meine
Geschichte
ich bin auch als Person in Indien groß
geworden dann in Luxemburg also ich
kenne diese zwei Kulturen hier ist es
ähnlich ja die Wissenschaft die
vielleicht eher manchmal verschlossen
Komplex weit weg ist und auf der anderen
Seite ein breitenmium wie das Fernsehen
was ich doch dem großen Publikum öffnet
und genau in dieser Schnittstelle äh
fühle ich mich wohl du
äh präsentierst das ja auch so wie du
beschreibst dass du es erklärst das
heißt du bemühst dich ja sehr darum ich
sag mal Form und Inhalt durch deine
Präsentation zusammenzubringen sehr äh
anschaulich aber auch nicht nur mit
Experimenten und Beispiel SP sondern
auch durch deine Art wie bist du auf die
ige gekommen hast du dir das mal
antrainiert hast du dich coachen lassen
macht man ja heutein nein das WE ich
weiß also ich habe nie ein Seminar für
Coaching gemacht ich habe nie all diese
Leute die einem sagen wie man es zu
machen hat und zwar von Anfang an also
vor vor über 20 Jahren als ich
anfing habe ich einen klaren Entschluss
gefasst ich habe gesagt ich kann nicht
anders ich ich finde es furchtbar wenn
Menschen sich verstellen wenn sie
irgendwo sich anbiedern schleimen oder
sonst was tun und ich habe gesagt so ich
mache es so und entweder akzeptiert man
es dann ist es okay oder man akzeptiert
es nicht dann to bad und ich kann mich
noch erinnern es gab so die ersten
Konflikte
1900 ich glaube 87 war es da gab es
einen Nobelpreis in der Chemie an
Jean-Marie len der hatte
ein Nobelpreis für
kronenetermoleküle also hohlraummoleküle
bekommen es geht darum man hat so
molekülstukturen die auch im Körper eine
Rolle spielen weil sie ja Dinge
identifizieren also Enzyme passen da
genau rein und so weiter und ich
überlegte wie erklärst du das und dann
kam ich auf die Idee Aschenputtel hatte
einen Schuh Aschenputtel verlor den
Schuh ja der Schuh ist auch ein Hohlraum
und mit dem Schuh suchte der
Prinz die wunderschöne
Prinzessin und genau das Verfahren ja
ist bei den hohlraummolekülen
ähnlich also nutzte ich das Beispiel
weil jeder kennt aschenpuddel und jeder
versteht sofort aha passt passt nicht
und dann monniierten einige Journalisten
sagten ha Aschenputtel und die
hohlraummoleküle und wie kann man das so
machen ich hatte nur das Glück
dass meine Ausbildung so solide war dass
jeder zumindest sag also der macht das
zwar komisch aber er scheint irgendwie
noch zu verstehen also von daher hat
mich das in der Anfangsphase ger und mit
der Zeit haben die Leute gemerkt hey das
warum nicht wir dürfen Metaphern
verwenden die manchmal bunt sind wenn
sie zum Verständnis führen gut und du
bist immer dabei geblieben hat ich nie
einer du musst dich jetzt mal coachen
lassen weil ich sag mal es gibt ja heute
kaum ein Moderator der nicht mehr ist
man sieht aber auch an ja nein das es
ist auch so dass ich mich nicht
schminken lass
dass ich gestern im Studio war und meine
Haare sind zu lang und die kamen alle
und sagten jetzt schneiden wir ich muss
dreingen zum Friseur ne sieht man ja
auch hab ich habe gesagt okay dann sind
sie mal zu lang also diese geklonen
gelackten glatten aussagelosen
neutralen Moderatoren die alle den Charm
von destilliertem Wasser haben finde ich
furchtbar und ich finde einfach das
Fernsehen das ist nämlich das Ergebnis
von Angst es ist dasselbe Problem wie in
der Politik wir haben Politiker die
inzwischen äh wie Automaten Dinge
abspulen wo ich frage wo ist die
Persönlichkeit wo ist das wo man mal
Kante gibt wo man sich positioniert wo
man vielleicht auch Kritik
einstecken muss aber wo man anders ist
und wir haben so eine einen Trend im
Moment ganz brav zu sein und überall im
Leben äh uns sozusagen stromlinienförmig
anzupassen die Autos sehen auch alle
gleich aus in meiner Kindheit sahen die
Autos komplett unterschiedlich aus wir
haben so dieses
alles gleich
so wenn wenn Leute genug Geld haben dann
redet man ihnen ein
dass sie sich ganz ein individuelles
Auto kaufen und wenn ich dann über den
Parkplatz gehe sehe ich nur schwarze
oder dunkelgraue Autos tolle
Individualität und du zeigst ja mit
deiner Individualität dass man damit
auch Erfolg haben kann und den ganzen
coachern Unrecht geben kann
wahrscheinlich gibt's auch coacher die
das eine oder andere sinnvolle sagen
also man man darf nicht autistisch oder
ich sag mal taub autistisch ist die
falsche Vokabel aber taub durchs Leben
gehen und nicht auf andere hören
aber der entscheidende Punkt ist es muss
aus einem selber kommen man darf nicht
Theater spielen man darf nicht irgendwas
vorgeben man darf auch mal einen Fehler
machen scheitern und zwar nicht
inszeniert das Fernsehen inszeniert es
dann immer und dann wird's ja sofort
übertrieben ähm ein bisschen Ehrlichkeit
Punkt super Schlusswort vielen Dank sehr
gerne